more fun for black but maybe what I can
do better right and so you wanted to ask
well what about the rover move well
seven of course I've got to put I gotta
put my my pawn and down the board
something like this I've got this move
Queen d8 check-in so I'm saying if you
play to move like Queen here to prevent
the park from promotion like I could
play Queen check anyway that Rover
doesn't look likely to keep an eye on
that pawn is more dangerous so that's
very conveniently prevents the salsify
playing Bishop to c7 which is a key
feature as well mm-hmm that's that's a
good that's a nice point and queen h5
checked I'm assuming that you don't want
to put your night on this defensive
square rather you want to play move like
Queen h2 and that pawn is still allowing
white I would say sufficient counter
playing this ending I I think it's
better for black I mean don't get me
wrong if we just trade trade go rook
here and play g5 and bring our King up
the board question is can Magnus hold it
so definitely the position big favorite
for fabula and the time like you said
three minutes from Magnus ten minutes
four five you all know you don't want to
go into this ending is black you how do
you want more of course so how about we
just try to round up the de pon
immediately so I guess you're you're
bringing your work to even one huh so
I'm trying to play both moves rook f6 as
well as rook e8 will most certainly be
met by walk even the other what if we
play the work out circle and then we
have work f3 and Queen h4
oh nice one I like that okay so rook f6
I can't stop for rook e1 thanks to this
sacrifice let us just make sure that
that is correct
it looks correct Jen you've got check
and you're just winning the rook with a
check so rook e1
is not on the cards rook f6 nice move oh
absolutely you get rid of that pawn on
e6 you take away the tooth have the
counter play that White has I don't know
this move rook f6 looks really good
Maurice what do our engines think about
this one well I hadn't looked at rook f6
yet but I think rook f6 looks like it
can be met by Queen B a check and
possibly East 7 the idea that this Queen
is always ready to come back to h2 to
defend mate so even a sacrifice here can
be met by a push no it seems that that
should cause a bit too much trouble
maybe we can look at that a little bit
later or a little bit deeper but Queen
d6 the move that the engine is saying is
actually rook to d8 harassing the Queen
trying to get it from finding a good
square and the rover you guys want to
play with Queen back to e5 is rook to d5
and now you're getting it the way you
want to get it going
however white can play this move still
Queen B a check King h7 and now E 7
allowing the move Queen to h5 and this
move if you play Knight back and this a
very important point then this attack is
just searing after takes takes Knight if
one takes and you're not getting away
this these checks are just brutal the
way the attack is going it's going to be
made soon a queen to g3 would be forced
here and then Queen check and all the
other lines work out as well the bishop
and Queen combination is just brilliant
along the dark squares so this idea of
playing rook to d5 allowing this check
and then this e 7 move check you would
have to respond with the move Queen to
h2 and this is somewhere weird because
now the engines are saying black can
simply play Queen back and what looks
like a natural move looks like rook to
e1 guarding runs into some kind of crazy
variation with Bishop f2 the idea being
to put this rook on H
five winning the game because you're
gonna win the queen or win everything
that's sitting right here
that's a beautiful shocking line it
still looks like something we need to
analyze deeply but that's the line it's
giving the reason why I'm bringing it up
it's so paradoxical looks weird you let
the pond go on e7 you're blockading with
the Queen so that you can attack with
the rook this part is still on e7 he can
even give away his queen to try to Queen
this pawn if you're not careful I'm not
sure far beyond who is gonna look at
that line and think yeah let me go down
that route but if he doesn't then the
interests are saying he's not better and
I think he's starting to look at it too
and say where's my win I'm supposed to
be winning right now but the wind that
he'd has to that tightrope he has to
walk does not look natural and I'm not
sure he's gonna find those moves
who would as that stuff looks weird yeah
it's true but on the other hand if
you're sitting there saying I
desperately want to make a rook over to
the F file then you know you look at
that Queen on d6 and say it's a
dominating Queen let's push that Queen
so rook d8 Queen e5 this to my mind
however is the hard move to find after a
seven
pardon me of Queen e8 you don't go Queen
h5 check so that you could go Queen e8 I
think it's much easier from the human
point of view to go okay I want to go
rook h5 Knight h2 and then you try to
figure out a way you know can my bishop
get down here and over here and mate and
if you come to the conclusion that can't
then you dismiss rook d8 so Queen h5 to
e8 as you say very paradoxical but very
beautiful variation and so far Fabiano's
calculation has not left anything to be
desired so maybe he will find this a
variation well here's one that more or
less is a little bit more human oh
pardon me
rook the what happened
it has been played Xavier on Colorado
now with six minutes in the clock and
Magnus Carlsen ticking down as less than
two and a half minutes here look at
feeling looking it's body language bear
looking very uncomfortable has and now I
said hey I think he's gonna play roof t5
exactly rook t5 looks very nervous and
Marissa share what do you got Omar's I
meant in another game completely like
that one went crazy the other game
that's a foot right now black is dead
lost he finally got to take on F two
guys but he did it at the worst moment
possible did Nakamura after rook takes
on e5
he played Knight to d5 with a discovery
on the f2 pawn big time threat of course
of winning the Queen and topalov said so
what you can have it now a long time ago
if you had played it I would have been
killed a second chance to maybe play for
the line I would have been in some kind
of trouble crazy position but now it's
over this check means nothing and he's
played the move has Nakamura Bishop
takes f2 and it's very simple
why can't just play king to h1 and
blacks position is falling apart you've
got a discovered threat with rook takes
threatened you've got Queen takes on c6
you've got 96 you've got so much stuff
it's ridiculous all of what black had is
simply gone I'm not even sure what move
to suggest here maybe let's try the move
Queen to d7
but after Bishop to e4 the white final
white piece leaps into the game this
rook is also coming to this Square on d1
so let's try and move I'm just gonna try
to defend but in this position the
engine is giving rook to a5 against my
move and that knight on d5 port look at
these white pieces oh my goodness look
at that King it's just it can't go
anywhere
it's just pinned every which direction
Nakamura finally got to take on f2 only
to find out that his position is just a
hot mess and he's going to lose this
game a terrible loss for him considering
that he could have taken f2 a long time
ago finally when he does so
it's over guys well this really does
remind what Levon Aronian said yesterday
about Veselin Topalov defense not as
forte but on offense virtually
unstoppable when he gets the type of
position he enjoys where he has the
initiative and he's attacking he has
taken down every single top chess player
in the world and as former world
champion when he's got the initiative he
is unstoppable and that's what happened
here
Bishop takes f2 huge missed opportunity
by he car earlier in the game and
unfortunately America's number 1 is
going down and as we started the show by
the way I said this is a key round
Veselin Topalov had that bull's-eye on
the back of his shirt a victory today
boy what would that do to lift his
confidence that's beyond a dream right
just by the way any wins of this
tournament to be appreciated but three
in a row for a while but beautiful
symmetry right no he comes back and has
this incredible tour today of course
he's had great timings before he get
such a high rating but this is really
just unbelievable I truly turning Norway
with 2-0 but starting this with perhaps
even 3-0 including a possible winning
and through I'll jump that would be
incredible and we do have this position
on the board rook to d5 was played we
got we BH at King H I'm in an e7 these
moves all being played quickly in both
players with just three minutes and four
minutes respectively on the clock big
question here h5 @ h5 Queen h5 has been
played so he did play Queen to h5 track
move that you said was so anti well the
paradoxical you take yeah you take this
attacking piece on g4 your Queen on g4
and you put it back to blockade the pawn
Maurice you had something you got to
share or is this surprising you that
that Fabiano has found this remarkable
idea shocking just amazing beautiful
these these kids grew up on computers
though when they grew up analyzing with
them and they start to see computer Eska
moves and it's just incredible to see
him playing this line where his queen is
going to have to block a tap a spawn and
use a rook to attack at the same time
and Carlsen having to find his moves as
well but I just I don't want to get away
from this game too long but I want to
show you something that's amazing that's
going on in the other game with Nakamura
and Topalov after this move Bishop F to
King H won this position looks as though
it is all-white Nakamura came up with a
truly spectacular variation himself rook
to b4 out of nowhere this is what he had
planned it turns out that it doesn't
work but it's gorgeous
if you look at it first of all it's
hanging this rook and Bishop takes on
this square suddenly the Queen takes on
e5 and he's looking for his own ideas in
case you move your bishop away this
Knight is hanging bit of craziness in
that position however if we back up here
he can win with the move Queen takes c6
he's planning to see Knight takes c3
with some chances but rook e8 is totally
winning in this position we can go into
this a little bit deeper but I don't
want to take away from the other game
which looks like it's going to be all
over quite soon Magnus Carlsen is losing
he played a line that does not work and
it looks like he's losing now back to
you guys that's right that lineman you
looked at earlier Yasser so instead of
Queen h2 allowing that Queen e8 move
which he found so difficult to find
instead magnets just played the other
line Knight h2o he looked at you one
checked which Maryse had pointed out a
long time ago it just ends in checkmate
and I think one check and has there been
a hand yes there has an admiral job to
suppress a smile he's doing his best
Wow incredible sports person starting
the tournament with 3-0 world champion
Magnus Carlsen and
sir a look at my board just unbelievable
you cannot believe what has taken place
here in the third round the secret cup
he looks exasperated Wow and fab you are
not to make eye contact it almost looks
like he feels a killer on the board but
then the moment the word is the game is
over he's like oh nice kid Wow and he
Carly he the strongest tournament of all
time with three wins in a row is is this
gonna be is this gonna be world champion
one day I recall the most phenomenal
result in the the illustrious career of
Anatoly Karpov I believe it was Linares
1994 I believe Anatoly Karpov started
6-0 6-0 in that event otherwise nothing
like it since the days of bobby fischer
right of course we have the Bobby
Fischer prize in the US Championship Rex
is very happy Wow alright Maurice what
do you have to say about this
spectacular start by the Italian
American first of all I'm amazed that
that Carlson missed his best line that
was so trivial why would you play 9h -
clearly you have to play Queen age -
that's maybe as shocking to me as a
three row start
how can Carlsen miss this simple line
who plays Knight H - allows rook d1 you
it's over right away that to me is
really really shocking to see the world
champion play this that I'm sure he's
gonna come down here and say what the
heck was I thinking that was awful how
could he do that
he just missed the idea that he's
getting made it in the end so that's a
shocker the three or no start certainly
a scintillating beginning to this
tournament the thing is if Topalov wins
check out the standings corona is going
to be a point and a half ahead of the
yield whoa I mean that's huge to start
off now there's still seven rounds to go
guys so anything could happen he could
lose a game he has started off strongly
before but we have to say this victory
does say a lot he played all the right
moves we can't complain about anything
he did and that sacrifice on f7 that
would have probably just totally scared
everybody else would have been peeing in
our pants if a world champion sacrifices
on f7 they kid was cool calm collected
did what he had to do rebuffed the
attack and proved that hey I hang with
the best so a tremendous start to this
tournament for Caruana a long way to go
but definitely a majestic victory and a
great beginning guys absolutely
incredible and we're gonna get both of
those players set up for interviews
shortly I assume so let's let's take a
look at our other game and also I'll go
over a couple of tweets Laurens trend
when you mentioned earlier in the show
says Carolina for president kids as cool
as a cucumber his biggest strength in my
opinion is his coolness insanely
talented he will be world champion one
day wow that's that's quite a prediction
pardon me in the game between Veselin
Topalov
and Hikaru Nakamura Maurice had pointed
out a variation that had gone Queen
takes c6 Knight takes c3 rook e8 as over
over signed the score sheets let's go
home that was not the best ones choice
vessel and instead captured oops I beg
your pardon he captured the rook on b4
Queen takes e5 and brought his bishop
out to e4 Bishop b4 pinning the knight
on d5 Bishop attacking the rook on f8
Queen attacking the bishop on c6 a lot
of black pieces are hanging in this
position I think that this was a winning
variation although I'm pretty sure that
Maurice was right that capturing on c6
right away would have ended everything
but as
we a mess I'm not easy to navigate all
these complication oh absolutely not
it's a it's a tactical slugfest going on
and he Carlos looks to be going down I
don't see a good move for him at the
moment and the time is 2 minutes for
Veselin 1 in 1 minute 40 yard seconds
for Hikaru and Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley about today's disappointing loss
I don't want to get away from that
exciting game for too long but just to
get a quick thought from you Magnus you
said here that you actually thought you
were winning in this position no I mean
I
before I was fighting for draw so I
don't know but I I had seen this
position from afar and I knew that I had
to play Queen edge too and because I
cannot because neither to work t1 and
then I wasn't satisfied with Queen edge
true and then I I looked for something
else and I I thought Knight h2 didn't
see any move except rookie 5 and then g4
and I thought wow I'm actually winning
this with position so and then of course
immediately after I made the move yeah
rook t1 and then Wow ghost this happen
to you must happen to you once every
five years maybe and ok it happens I
mean the position was I mean if I cannot
say V 7 then the position is probably
very bad anyways at least I could have
put a fight this sacrifice on f7
tremendous sacrifice did you think you
were winning equal unclear what was your
assessment when you play the move I
thought I played pretty badly in the
opening there was a little bit worse and
it seemed to me that after the sacrifice
I would have some interesting
possibilities but I mean this move
Knight III was amazing I didn't see that
at all I think he had some other options
as well but that was a nice one and then
I was definitely under some pressure but
I hope that my
porn would give me enough counterplay
you've had a lot on your mind you're not
playing well right now
it seems in the tournament you had a
tough Olympian as well anything going on
your forum just seems to not be quite
there this this last tournament and now
this one I mean I my play was not so
great today but the last two today's
it's been good so let's not draw too
many conclusions that what's it gonna
take to come back this guy's at three
points now he's two full points ahead of
you and he'll the way top allows game is
going he's gonna be a point a half ahead
of the field how Quran is playing
magnificent chess it looks like yeah but
it sort of helps when I suppose blender
as well but yeah he's playing he's
playing very well and obviously and
they'll have to beat him probably to
stop it with it it's a long way to go
people have crashed and burned before
okay well best of luck in the rest of
your games we hope you regain your form
and yeah I guess the lock world champion
Magnus Carlsen after losing to number
two or three or something else in the
world
uh-huh Fabiana Khurana back to you guys
well no more flip-flopping as far as
number 2 is concerned to Fabiano has
definitely taken his a firm grip on the
number 2 spot by rating and we see
interview meanwhile Uehara Nakamura
shaking his head vigorously what does
that mean yeah
question Karen and now at 28 15 or 20
816 according to grandmaster young
Gustafson so that's pretty high up there
oh yeah oh yeah I'm pretty decent so
here we got that we were at this
position after Bishop before I didn't
see a good move for cara cara played
rook f6 which is about as best as he
could hope for he's just getting his
rook out of on free as well as defending
his bishop then came the natural rook d1
just you know putting added pressure
against the knight on d5 King g7 and he
carros down to a minute and I'm looking
at this right best ones down to 330
seconds let's take a quick look and
confirm the clock times as we get five
Yano Carolina our tournament leader set
up for an interview with Maurice Ashley
right and I believe we have seen another
move after rook d1 just a second I think
we've seen Bishop takes T fine hold on
let me get an update on the board that's
our clock times it looks like laughs in
a minute for each player yep but that
30-second bonus is deceptive Wow Queen
takes and we're here and oh it's over
it's just a whole piece up and keep
keeping in mind that this Bishop is
about to relocate itself on the long
diagonal absolutely n I think we're
about to see a handshake it's over so
three decisive results the thing feel
Cup and speaking of threes we also have
a player with three points out of three
perfect score right mr. perfect
so Fabiano Carolina the leader of the
Sinquefield pop by unbelievable miss he
is with crime master Maurice Ashley with
the tournament leader Grandmaster
Fabiana kawana we said number three in
the world number two in the world some
people are starting to say number one
let's not jump the gun too much first of
all congratulations on your win thank
you were you surprised that by the
finish you must have seen that he had
Queen to h2 and there would be some game
to go and suddenly he play Knight h2 and
the game was over I felt like I had a
big advantage but I thought there would
be a long way to go I'm not h2 it was a
shock for me I'm not sure what he missed
maybe yeah actually I can't really
explain his blunder maybe he just
blundered rook T woman so but I still
felt that I had good chances to win but
I mean against Magnus he's such a good
defender you never know
threa no of course everybody gets
excited the media gets excited to press
the fans how are you feeling at it 3 and
OH start still a long way to go okay
okay it's a great start I mean I
couldn't couldn't go for better it's
true and I really didn't expect anything
like this especially since I was
starting with two blacks and today I
yeah I didn't expect to win it all
things just went very well from the
opening and in general things have gone
very well for me here when he took on f7
you came back to the board it seemed
like this is not a move you looked at oh
is that true cuz he you seem surprised
by his move no I had seen the move
before I played 95 but I realized that I
hadn't checked it thoroughly enough
which is a bit embarrassing because it's
such a critical move are you afraid of
maybe dying in the moment when you you
come back to the board and see the guys
sacked at Bishop 107 yeah I was afraid
that I had missed something but it turns
out that blacks position I think is okay
it is at least the core to the engines
it is so you seem fine
yeah it's of course a crazy position but
I think that only black could be better
after that Wow it's a cool assessment
well you're at 3 you know going into
tomorrow game you have the white pieces
what's your mindset well still try to
play my best I think I have to I mean
ice just have to keep on playing good
chess and and things will work out wise
worries well congratulations on your
victory and best of luck in the rest of
the games
and the question had Magnus played the
move Queen h2 what was his intended
response to Queen age - so yes sir is
asking about this this possibility of
Queen age - what were you going to do
can we get the position sure I need the
mouse Queen age five yeah I was going to
play Queen e8 and okay rook e1 I think
is forced
I thought his forced apparently bishop
of two just wins I was I wasn't eddying
to play rook h5 here [ __ ] she was much
stronger bishop f2 is a very strong the
point is now rookie four I don't go to
h5 but I go to d1 right and he's going
to lose a piece if I eat if I had played
route page five instead then then Knight
h4 is maybe not as clear ok still very
good for black but the problem here is
that after Bishop f2 rookie four which
is what I didn't see and it looks like
he might be holding on with this yeah
crazy position it's possible well you
probably would have found Bishop f2
given given some time on the clock in
the position in front of you hopefully
you didn't have to worry about that I
mean we were looking at it I would say
it's a real kudos to find this
paradoxical idea of Queen h5 to e8 when
did that first occur - Fabiano to bring
your attacking Queen back to blockade
the e7 pawn well I when he played Queen
e6 I thought this is a very clever move
I hadn't seen it in advance and after
about 10 minutes of thought I got pretty
desperate because I didn't see any way
to keep my advantage and eventually I I
realized that uh that this is the pretty
much the only way to play rook da trick
g5 and yeah when I saw Queen e8 I've got
pretty excited I would have been that
excited having to put my queen on e8
I'll tell you that much but that's why
he's number two in the world right now
2,800 player and leading our tournament
guys applause just just great stuff big
Bravo
avianna wonderful wonderful game and
defeating the world champion in such
fine style you just have to say tip of
the hat well done well done so what
about our tweeters is says Magnus
crossing 0-3 the darkest moment of his
career no one so and with seven rounds
to go still plenty of drama to be held
left at this tournament Wow but if
Fabiana continues to play the scorching
chess that he's played so far in this
event
he looks untouchable and he's just plain
beautiful beautiful beautiful dress
perfect start just a simply a perfect
start meanwhile we're getting the u.s.
number-one player Hikaru Nakamura he's
setting up for his interview about today
is also thrilling game against
definitely a top ala why didn't
opportunity he had today boy well it's
what's good right that's good they're
all words on it yes here he is Nakamura
he's with Grandmaster Maurice Ashley
with Hikaru Nakamura after losing a
tough game Hikaru there was a moment in
the game that the computer spotted an
idea and we thought you were for sure
gonna play it's a kind of move you
always play yeah sure said you played in
a bullet game the move Bishop takes f2
tell us your thoughts in this moment
right now well I mean basically I had
this exact position up until move
nineteen on the you know before the game
and if I was not a computer move so I
knew it had to be bad but during the
game I just couldn't quite figure it out
okay obviously I looked at Bishop takes
f2 and then I then I rejected it but I
mean I I just simply didn't see the end
of the line I mean more or less
it's just unfortunate but even later I
was probably still so okay and then I
just completely lost the threat so I
mean sometimes things don't go your way
the we hear this often is refrain from
really high-level players like yourself
that just some something goes wrong in
the calculation
can you ever explain it when that
happens because it seems unnerving even
to you guys
well I mean I'm not so upset about
missing this one because I mean it
wasn't clear even though it's I mean the
most intuitive move on the board so I
mean I mean sometimes it happens but
again what can you do sometimes
sometimes you don't I mean you don't
calculate perfectly we're not computers
I mean that's well that's why that's why
computers are just much better than all
of us well at least in calculation for
sure you're in a tough situation now but
but also with the number-one player in
the world who just got got blitzed today
or at least blundered horribly well what
was your assessment of the way he lost
the game I just played a bad bad game I
mean he just should have played a better
opening but I mean all right he lost a
game he's obvious Magnus is obviously
still a very good player so anything can
happen but okay right now I'm just going
to try and play something better than
today at least tomorrow final thought
what's happening at this tournament
there's winds everywhere this never
happens in a GM tournament three rounds
decisive games everyone more than 50%
victories what's going on to the guy
that they insist to you guys have to
play like crazy chess before the
tournament I think everyone's just
everyone's just trying on to win games
and that's what happens when players
don't play boring opening so I guess
it's good for the Adhan certainly we
appreciate having fighting chess players
like yourself sometimes it works out
sometimes it doesn't
we hope it works out for you in the rest
of your games thank you no more an
employer in the United States after a
tough loss Hikaru Nakamura back to you
guys Jenny yes Wow
what a turn of events Jen I just can't
say enough I came to the show yeah well
I came to the show with this very strong
feeling that although it was early and
we're gonna overuse the word critical I
thought today was a critical round I
thought that vessel and having lost two
games needed a victory to get his
confidence back and he succeeded
admirably I thought that the game
between Caruana Magnus was huge for the
outcome the eventual outcome of who wins
first I thought
Magnus really needed a win and there is
a Nakamura needling his opening choice
right okay thank you for the advice and
it turned out yeah exactly and it turned
out to be boy I called it this was a
crucial round from every perspective and
we have that's it former world champion
Veselin Topalov to explain to us about
his first victory and how good and how
good that feels winning always feels
good guys no matter what I'm sure he's
going to agree with Grandmaster Veselin
Topalov welcome to the show
congratulations on your victory
much-needed victory you were down in the
hole was your mindset coming into this
game playing against Nakamura today well
I mean it's you know I don't have this
problem of think about the result it's
just the way I'm I think it's totally
different like I'm going for the game
and you know it's not about a result
somehow so today of course I want but
it's it was from my point of view quite
a terrible game we both missed really a
lot and it was far below the level we
should show somehow but ok of course
it's definitely better to win than to
lose but you know we missed some
especially Hikaru he missed some simple
moves or maybe they were not so simple
but you know he could have won in
probably 20 moves with black this move
Bishop oh yeah did you not sure did you
see it at the board were stylists that
that was the reason I spend so much time
but someone suddenly I realized that
simply it looked very nice for me and I
had some moves like before playing a g5
some before this you want to go yeah I
mean here my original intention was to
go some e6000 twerk you know it looked
very nice that I have all my pieces
and black looks likes the 90s miss
played but of course first if I the both
nights are on you know on the rail under
but it looks like black is completely
fine maybe even better so because if I
move my night then the problem is that
black changed queens and then attacks my
pawn so I mean of course I blundered
because here you know that yeah the line
original I thought that I can suck a
queen you know but of course it just
yeah check rookie three rookie five
check yes and then I thought I have some
chances after 93 and 95 but apparently
just nothing yeah I thought it that
night if six was a good move but then I
had some tricks but maybe just like
Bishop d3 and keeping some chances but
probably of course with the computer
it's probably not true well but to find
all these moves again computers okay
find them but not humans well but of
course it's not only one move probably
black has more than one good moves here
so it's not like only moves that win so
maybe they're also after I didn't really
consider moved g6
the pawn but I thought that Knight f6
was stronger because then night the
knight cannot go to d7 so okay it's
truly dial I was lucky and then the
other position which I kind of didn't
really I think here he cover his plate
because Bishop d5 was stronger because
black is simply waiting for my ignite to
move and then the knight goes to see for
protecting the square e five and then I
think here it was already quite good for
me but Bishop d2 looks very natural move
but
you know Knight h5 I was just told that
it was a possibility for black but well
you know there are moves like 93 and
then always the the bishop goes to 2 C 3
and somehow here I thought that I'm
already much better and then okay e5 is
losing move but by many ways probably
but I don't know if I did all the best
moves but probably I never missed well
this is fighting chess and in crazy
chess I have to ask you what did you
think about the game with Carlsen going
down so badly to Cara wanna know okay
it's not really a big surprise because I
think Fabiano his oneness
I mean he's fighting for first place in
almost every tournament
so it's he's at the moment number 2 so
number 1 losing to number 2 it's not
really a big surprise you know do you
feel as some people are starting to
claim that he's got real claims to talk
about being the next world champion
actually you know to become world
champion you just have to win the road
championship
that's only one way you know you can be
announced as a world champion I think so
okay it he the way he keeps playing
obviously he has the world championship
strength or close to world championship
strength but he has to prove it you know
the way everybody did it like Magnus and
Anand before so but okay he's very young
so I'm sure that he will get involved in
in the in the fight for the title is he
the main rival to to Carlsen the like v1
right now at the moment I believe yes
okay of course we have to see the shape
of Anand because I believe that in a
match a new match between crossing an
island
I don't give such a big advantage to
Magnus as as before I think of course
the way and it was he can do much better
I mean then what he did in India but
still
should be a favorite and Fabiano he has
everything because he's also even a
little bit younger than Magnus and he
seems like he has a good confidence
playing with him like he's already
winning many games and it's a big fight
between them which I love to see a match
you know in the evil I think we were all
obviously that match last question is is
the tournament over oh no I don't
believe so because I especially Magnus I
mean many times he started badly like I
remember that two times the two Grand
Slam finals he won in Bilbao that he was
always the first like he was always not
starting not so well and then winning
almost all the games in the second leg
but that's also true that it was a
different point system with three points
for win so but you know I don't believe
it the tournament is over no not yet
well thanks so much and congratulations
your victory today we know your great
fighting spirit and fighting style we
always appreciate your games Grandmaster
Veselin Topalov after a good victory
today guys it's been a great day
couldn't like a former world champion
and the man of experience to win the
World Championship you have to win the
World Championship it's absolutely right
we can speculate all we want but you got
to prove it over the board that guy
loves chess you could see when offer the
prospects of carolina across and match
games like that oh that would be great
well I guess come on oh and particularly
like that yes
but as Cara Nakamura said they're
playing exciting chess because they're
here to win him because they're playing
exciting openings
everybody is so let's take a look at all
the standings and the Sinquefield Cup as
we go into round 4
Fabiano Khurana
with a perfect 300 score who would have
expected that he's a 1 and a half points
ahead of his nearest rival Levon Aronian
and Maxime bashier lira
both with one and a half points and
here's something you don't see every day
magnus carlsen hydrolyzed shocking with
one point but as you pointed out he
thought he played pretty well in round
one into an idea great get back in there
and of course we also have taupe I love
and you car Nakamura with one point
exactly final thought for Maurice Ashley
about today's absolutely thrilling
contests incredible watching chest like
this better than 50% positive results
wins everywhere mistakes blunders we
love it it's the drama that makes us
love chess fighting chess in all the
games and Cara Juana with such a lead
how can you be leading by a point and a
half after three rounds usually that
math is impossible just doesn't make any
sense it as you mentioned Carlsen tied
for last
that's almost unbelievable but Cara
Juana is such an impressive player we
are seeing the makings of a new champion
of course Carlson's gonna have to have a
thing or two to say about that and
there's a long way to go seven rounds he
could always collapse one loss brings
him right back with the rest of the
field so no way we can count this
tournament as anywhere near over fact I
don't even wanted to be over let's just
keep going after ten rounds the way
these guys are playing I've such
magnificent fighting chess here at the
Sinquefield Cup you've got to love it
guys Maurice when you said this round
was better than and paused for a while I
say something totally different but
indeed this was one of those incredible
rounds and I've ever commented on it's
been unbelievable I couldn't I was
really in shock when I saw like one game
after another exploding so the sign is
you just don't want to miss one day of
the same field cop we're running away to
tune in we're running out of
superlatives I mean I hadn't found for
it
panic possibly get any more exciting
than what we've experienced let's just
say yes because we've been wrong too
many no we're not gonna say yes
part of it is gonna continue to heat up
so tune in every day 150 Central
Standard Time and that is 250 over in
the East Coast so give you that 10
minute pregame show and then we'll get
right in to round for action at the
scene field cup big game is going to be
carrion ax versus Bologna on and don't
miss it
let's see your Maura